calificado de espía por Washington y de
civil por Beijing casi dos semanas
después de haber derribado este
artefacto chino que sobrevolaba el
territorio estadounidense el presidente
Joe biden se dirigió al país según él su
destrucción Envía un claro mensaje
contra cualquier violación de la
soberanía de Estados Unidos
estén seguros que si un objeto aéreo
supone una amenaza para la seguridad
estadounidense lo Haré derribar el
mandatario añadió que no quería una
nueva guerra fría entre los dos países
Espero poder hablar con el presidente
She e ir al fondo de este caso
Beijing sostiene que se trataba de un
civil destinado a recoger datos
meteorológicos y que se adentró
involuntariamente en el espacio aéreo
estadounidense el incidente desencadenó
un impase diplomático entre ambos países
y debido a ello el secretario de estado
Anthony blinquen se vio obligado a
suspender una visita a territorio chino
china por su parte también hizo
señalamientos contra Washington de
presunto espionaje
desde mayo del año pasado Sin la
aprobación de las autoridades chinas
pertinentes Estados Unidos ha lanzado
varios globos de Gran altitud desde
Estados Unidos que han realizado vuelos
continuos por todo el mundo sobrevolando
ilegalmente el espacio aéreo de China y
otros países pertinentes al menos 10
veces desde el incidente del globo chino
otros tres objetos no identificados han
sobrevolado el territorio estadounidense
y han sido derribados por las fuerzas
aéreas Pero biden dijo que las agencias
de inteligencias seguían buscando más
información el presidente pidió además a
su administración que haga un mejor
inventario de los objetos que vuelan en
el cielo de Estados Unidos y anunció
haber establecido un diálogo con sus
aliados sobre lo que cree que es el
programa de espionaje de China